but ryan reynolds who is i mean v
how hot on a scale of one to ten is he a
10 out of 10 or an 11 out of 12.
he's he could get it yeah he [ __ ] get
it yeah i mean all i tell you what
people differ a lot on brad pitt leo but
every single white girl you ask has
[ __ ] ryan reynolds at the top of the
list and i don't know why
because he's got a punchable nose he
looks like he's got a nose that was
corrected
by surgery because someone punched him
in it well i mean he's ripped he's
shredded he's funny
he seems like he's down to earth um and
he got married on a slave plantation
so that's the thing boom plantation
which i've been to which is gorgeous
um he's been canceled and he issued an
apology for it
which you know he didn't mean because he
got married there now
is this is this bad i don't know i feel
like we got to ask our black fans
because
part of me was thinking i've been there
it obviously is a slave plantation slave
plantations are bad
but the house is now used for something
else and it is a gorgeous
i mean you know it's gorgeous i mean
george washington's monticello for all
uh for all intents and purposes was a
slave plantation
but it's gorgeous you know i don't know
if you can get married there i mean
what's the ruling on this
i just feel like i can't this is
something i feel like definitely
black people need to make a ruling on
i'm going to ask bennett if she can text
her group chat and find out before the
show's over
yeah can you text your pereira and find
out what this is or maybe we can just
ask our black fans we'll put it on
the um we'll put it on the patreon and
find out is this wrong
yeah it's just wrong we're not sure um
but any anywho he apologized which
obviously as you guys have to know and
understand right now nobody means their
apologies at all
he knew that it was a slave plantation
nobody the prob because the thing is i
don't think it's really that big of a
deal but there's nothing else going on
so they want to just
make everyone apologize and make
everyone say they're sorry so
these groups feel powerful so he'll just
do it just to get them away
and then move on but i mean he'll get
you know that guy it doesn't matter
he'll get married in auschwitz tomorrow
it doesn't matter
hair loss may be a coronavirus symptom
so is your hair good because your hair
looks like it's coming back
explain that to me explain why my hair
sometimes looks like it's missing and
why sometimes it looks
completely full explain it i don't i
have
i think sometimes you get corona i think
i think you go back and forth with
getting corona
yeah i mean a fan of our podcast dm the
other day and said that i
did i put up am i 300 pounds now because
he saw the luke's excitement video and
he said you look fat
but then he said he watched weapon the
morning and i got skinny again
so yeah what's going on because i don't
know what's going on
do you have clothes do you have did you
did you bring clothes from new hampshire
are you just going to go
dirty not clean ass today to do the show
i
i'm going to shower but yeah we're going
to do a two-day draws
thank you so okay yeah cause i was i'm
gonna go for a jog on shore road
uh i could go with you because i could
always just put i got clothes
in the hamper here that i can put yeah
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]